Speaker 1: as if you didn't already suspect
that Nikki Haley's 2024 Republican presidential
campaign was off to a bad start. We've learned
that she has been dramatically overstating the
amount of money she has raised and the campaign
looks to be, I don't want to say dead on arrival,
but very, very close. So The Washington
Post reporting Nikki Haley's campaign vastly
overstating her fundraising. Listen to this.
Instead of the $11 million touted by her campaign,
Haley brought in about 8.3 million. Not all
of which can even be used for the presidential
campaign. They had been talking about 11 million
in six weeks. But now that the filings have been
made with the FEC, that was an over exaggeration.
The campaign appears to have double counted money.
It moved among various committees, committees.
The filings covering the first three months of
the year show that three committees affiliated
with Haley collectively brought in 8.3 million.
Haley's joint fundraising committee raised about
4.4 million. The campaign committee's haul of 5.1
million included 1.8 million from that other
committee. So a bunch of that money was double
counted. And this is all being considered highly
unusual. The Trump campaign Saturday said they
brought in about 14 and a half million and then
another 4.3 million into the leadership PAC and
on and on and on. Now, the funniest part of this
is not all of that 8.3 million can actually be
used for the campaign because the leadership
PAC is typically only to boost allies or to
promote a message not directly to finance her
own campaign. So, listen, this is pretty bad.
This is pretty bad. And there's two ways to
interpret this. One way to interpret it is
the fact that Nikki even raised eight, even though
she can only use a fraction of it. That's already
amazing for a candidate who isn't doing that well
in the polls. The counterpoint would be this is
probably the most attention she will ever get.
This was the big moment, and she still wasn't able
to raise that much money and it didn't do anything
for her in the polling. And indeed, the polling
doesn't look very good. Her best poll right now
is a particular Iowa poll which which has her in
third place at 14% behind Trump and a guy who's
not even running yet, Ron DeSantis, that's her
best showing. Most polling has Nikki Haley at two,
three or 4%, for example, in the Kentucky primary.
She's at 4% in the Georgia primary. She is at
4%. So a couple of different thoughts here. One,
I don't think we had to wait for these numbers
from both polling and fundraising to be able to
say this campaign's probably not going anywhere.
At the same time, there's the perspective that the
campaign doesn't really need to go anywhere in the
sense that Nikki Haley. I mean, listen, you know,
people have asked me before when someone like
Nikki Haley announces, given what the polling is,
does Nikki Haley actually think she can win? I
don't know the answer. I've never actually asked
these candidates. Do. You don't really think you
can win, do you? I'm sure she wouldn't admit it
if she didn't think she could win. But there's a
particularly unique situation in this in this 2024
Republican primary, which is Nikki Haley could be
running as an audition for VP. That's something
that's been discussed and that I think should be
considered and not ruled out. Sure, she might be
running for VP. Trump certainly seems to think
that she is. And also there is the usefulness of
more candidates to Trump, because when you look
at 2024 polling, one of the things that you'll
notice is in head to head matchups between Trump
and DeSantis, DeSantis does better, not better
than Trump. He's still mostly losing to Trump,
but he does better than when you have. Trump,
DeSantis, Haley Pence, Tim Scott, Vivek Ramaswamy,
and whoever else. The more candidates you have,
the better it actually is for Trump. So
there's also the speculation or the idea
that Trump liked the idea of Nikki Haley running
because it actually helps him. Needless to say,
this is a campaign that, as a presidential
campaign, was doomed from day one as a vice
presidential audition remains to be
seen. And we will indeed see that.